symbolique des 2 euros le litre de
carburant déjà dépassé dans plusieurs
grandes villes françaises et cette
question que peut faire le gouvernement
pour alléger la facture flora sauvage
plan b des prix du gaz des céréales ou
des matières premières l'impact de la
guerre en ukraine sur l'économie
française était au menu des discussions
entre jean castex les représentants des
filières concernées et les organisations
syndicales et patronales ce mardi le
gazole ainsi augmenté de 14 centimes le
litre en moyenne la semaine dernière
depuis l'invasion russe en ukraine ya
pas qu il en soit le 11 août là aussi la
vie de tous les jours et les payes
augmente fort devant la flambée des prix
à la pompe le chef de l'état a promis
d'améliorer les aides sur l'essence il y
aura une mesure supplémentaire sur la
partie essence qui est une mesure qui va
permettre un d'aller plus loin sur
l'indemnité inflation mais immédiate et
qui doit renforcer y compris en
synchronisant l'équivalent de
l'indemnité kilométrique s'il est réélu
le président candidat s'est engagé à
supprimer la redevance télé et à tripler
le plafond de la prime macron qui
permettent aux entreprises de verser
jusqu'à 1000 euros sans charges ni impôt
mais pour les syndicats il faut aller
encore plus loin la course à l'échalote
de la petite mesure fiscale par le bout
de la lorgnette je suis pas tellement
fan je pense qu'il ya besoin de reposer
la question de la dette des politiques
fiscales au sens large du terme si le
gel des prix du gaz devrait coûter 10
milliards d'euros le plafonnement des
tarifs de l'électricité représente 8
milliards et l'indemnité inflation 4
milliards d'euros au total la facture
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français s'élève à 22 milliards d'euros
selon l'exécutif pour faire face aux
conséquences économiques du conflit en
ukraine le gouvernement prépare un plan
de résilience ce plan sera au menu des
discussions jeudi et vendredi prochain
au sommet des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne qui
se tiendra à versailles les conséquences
de cette guerre en ukraine sur notre
pouvoir d'achat ou là le thème de notre
débat et je présente mes invités
stéphanie villers bonjour économiste
spécialiste de la zone euro joséphine
staron bonjour docteur en philosophie
directrice des études et des relations
internationales du cercle de réflexion
silo pierre françois lévesque bonsoir à
vous aussi professeur d'économie à
l'école des mines paris c'est le
spécialiste du secteur de l'énergie
c'est fanny villers ces chiffres + 14
centimes pour le litre de gazole qui
rejoint le litre de sans plomb ça va
continuer évidemment cette hausse jusqu
où est ce qu'on peut déjà anticiper le
mouvement c2c c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs c'est ça
dépend aussi du temps que va prendre
cette cette guerre cette crise et
surtout des du sens qu'elle va
véritablement
prendre est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
envenimement de ou au contraire est-ce
qu'on va arriver à une résolution rapide
et ça a les économistes maîtrise pas
cette donnée là donc bon il vaut mieux
en fait envisager le pire pour s'y
préparer en fait et faire de nos modèles
en fonction à d'une montée inexorable
des prix à la fois du pétrole et du gaz
laetitia bonjour j'ai oublié de vous
présenter le tissu écru pas détaillé ce
politique qui est à mes côtés g vas-y
quand même comme chaque mardi et chaque
jeudi et droits des femmes oui ça tombe
bien vous avez raison ça tombe très bien
mais bref ça doit être tous les jours ça
va justement françois levêque 7 cette
hausse elle intervient alors qu'on est
déjà dans une phase aussi il ya déjà eu
des échecs inflation des chèques énergie
des coups de pouce du gouvernement donc
on est dans un contexte qui est déjà
particulier voilà ce qui a deux
séquences il yal'avant 24 février 2022
depuis l'automne les prix du pétrole du
gaz et de l'électricité à ont connu des
hausses très importante ce qui a conduit
d'ailleurs le pouvoir exécutif a
installé des boucliers à vouloir
protéger les consommateurs les ménages
mais aussi les entreprises et première
phase est la deuxième phase on entre
dans une poursuite dans une accélération
dans une augmentation de l'augmentation
c'est à que d'une croissance a accéléré
des prix du pétrole et des prix du gaz
voilà ce qui est en train de se passer
on a un prix du baril à quai à 130
130 euros
on a le on a des prix de l'électricité
qui sera absolument astronomiques et le
prix du gaz flambe c'était ce crime par
de spéculations dans le dans le fénoir
ya surtout il ya surtout à une panique
mais a surtout une panique y compris un
y compris des opérateurs financiers et
donc le prix il a pas il n'est pas
vraiment relié aux coûts là le prix il
est relié ben voilà on a peur que nature
a pas assez de vieilles aura pas assez
de gaz y aura pas assez de pétrole pour
l'europe en fonction de différentes
interventions à venir sur les
importations venant de russie et donc
voilà c'est c1 pris de panique
mais qui peut durer assez longtemps et
qu'elle y est effectivement un ces
inconnus j'ai compris que les militaires
et parlait du brouillard de la guerre
voilà et bien je pense qu'il ya le
brouillard de l'économie quand on est en
temps de guerre
joséphine stars ont cette flambée est
plus on l'a vu elle a déjà des
conséquences sur notre économie pour
l'instant on va dire que les français
n'acceptent jeu pendant combien de temps
encore pendant la question c'est jusqu'à
quand effectivement si le conflit dure
et on a l'impression que c'est le cas
puisque aujourd'hui tout se met en
marche pour qu'on soit prêt dans le
cadre d'un conflit dont aujourd'hui
l'union européenne vient d'annoncer un
plan qui s'appelle riou donc pour
repenser notre notre projet énergétique
globale c'est-à-dire à la fois la
diversité des approvisionnements là le
stockage du gaz pour être prêt et puis
répondre à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie donc tout un package pour
répondre à ça dans le cadre d'un conflit
qui devrait durer donc on s'y prépare
maintenant on a un peu l'impression que
c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte qu'il
continue qui a commencé avec la crise
sanitaire qui a continué avec le début
de l'augmentation des prix et puis qui
maintenant on va dire se sacralise
presque avec cette crise ukrainienne qui
va durer alors quoi qu'il en coûte mais
il va quand même en coûter est-ce que ce
coup les français et les européens vont
accepter de le supporter longtemps la
vraie question c'est est-ce qu'ils vont
avoir le choix parce qu'aujourd'hui on à
joe biden le président américain qui
annonce
un embargo sur les importations de
pétrole et de gaz les européens vont
probablement suivre c'est tout le sens
de ce nouveau programme européen en
urgence donc est ce qu'on aura le choix
d'accepter cette nouvelle donne mondiale
alors effectivement on va en débattre de
sa de cette annonce par par joe biden
mais laëtitia ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il ya des voix qui s'élèvent
qui s'élevaient déjà en france pour
justement arrêté d'acheter le gaz russe
oui c'est effectivement une des
sanctions par exemple évoqué par l'ex
président de la république françois
hollande dans une tribune au monde il
plaide pour un embargo du gaz russe il
dit qu'il faut t'il alors se résigner au
statu quo en considérant que nous ne
disposons d'aucune alternative et que
nous ne pouvons malgré une solidarité
sincère et l'écart du peuple ukrainien
payer plus cher notre énergie et prendre
le risque parce que c'est bien le sale
attente il s'agit prendre le risque de
ne pas nous chauffer l'hiver prochain
donc il y a des voix bien sûr qui
s'élève côté politique alors pour le
moment ce sont d'ex responsables parce
que à la suite de françois hollande nous
avons aujourd'hui hier soir par exemple
bernard kouchner ex-ministre des
affaires étrangères sur bfmtv faire la
même demande en précisant que le pétrole
et le gaz sont les principales sources
de revenus du régime de vladimir poutine
en écoute
arrêtons d'acheter
peut-on arrêter d'acheter le gaz et le
pétrole en russie ce qui nous vaudrait
de notre côté des restrictions terrible
est-ce que ça n'est pas la seule
solution pour une europe qui voudraient
faire quelque chose qui n'a pas de
défense et qui n'a pas l'intention
d'être en guerre voilà parce que c'est
vrai que si on ne va pas en guerre et si
on est uniquement sur ce volet des
sanctions il faut bien trouver quelque
chose qu'ils arrêtent vladimir poutine
or vous l'avez dit madame et vous avez
raison si les états unis ont décidé et
ça bientôt hélas cet après-midi de
mettre un embargo et d'interdire les
importations de pétrole et de gaz russe
en europe on ne parle pas d'une seule
voix il y à l'allemagne qui freinent des
quatre pieds des quatre fers parce
qu'elles apportent près de 50% de son
gaz depuis la russie et lundi à la chose
le chancelier a été très clair il a dit
que pour le moment ses importations a
été essentielle pour la vie quotidienne
des citoyens en europe et donc que pour
le moment ça ne pouvait pas être assurée
autrement donc est ce que la france peut
et ça c'est une question que je vous
pose à tous prendre ce type de décisions
seul il me semble que non mais peut-être
que vous avez une réponse à les
transports avec lotfi je pense tout
d'abord qu'il faut trouver des solutions
raisonnables et donc on n'est pas dans
un débat où on arrête de d'importer du
pétrole et du gaz de russie no vous
n'est pas sur une solution au 01 c'est
que on peut choisir d'un d'arrêter
complètement les importations de pétrole
par exemple parce que il ya une certaine
facilité à trouver d'autres sources pour
s'approvisionner en pétrole c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour le gaz mais
pour le gaz on peut très bien imaginer
que certains pays on peut très bien
imaginer des quotas si vous voulez que
progressivement par exemple ha ha ha à
l'horizon un an et réduisent laissera
les approvisionnements d'un quart venant
de russie on n'est pas dans une et là
les états unis les états unis mais les
états unis sont pas du tout un dans la
situation énergétique de l'europe les
etats-unis sont excédentaires en pétrole
il s'exporte ils ont du gaz qu'est pas
cher et l'importation voilà au cabba il
n'ya pas y'a pas le coup d'un embargo
total des états unis est relativement
faible pour les américains il est
beaucoup plus élevé pour les européens
il est plus élevé pour certains citoyens
en europe et donc il peut y avoir des
solutions graduelle on n'est pas dans un
monde du tout au rien imaginé et on peut
imaginer lui les risques de subtilité
dans les résolutions non mais maintenant
il ya quand même en face une menace qui
errait c'est à dire qu'il vaut mieux
voir noah notre facture énergétique
explose et où se lancer dans une
troisième guerre mondiale avec les
risques qu'on connaît je pense que on a
tout simplement plus le choix si on veut
éviter une escalade avec un risque de de
guerre d'autant que l'europe n'a pas du
tout envie donc notre seule arme c'est
bel et bien cet embargo sur le pétrole
et le gaz ça va nous en coûter et je
pense que cette réunion au sommet la 2e
à versailles va permettre de définir les
grandes lignes pour essayer de limiter
la casse et là où en fait le ca à sa
tombe assez bien c'est que c'est
l'allemagne qui est la plus pénalisée
dans cette histoire c'est elle qui s'est
mis en situation de totale dépendance
vis-à-vis de la russie or on sait que
vis-à-vis de l'union elle a vraiment du
mal à envisager une politique budgétaire
commune parce que elle trouve que ce
sont les autres pays qui dépense plus
que et eux sont plutôt dans la rigueur
balla ils ont besoin en fait de ses
soutiens c'est évident ça arrive à un
consensus eux sont bons si vous voulez
ils vont changer de l'aï d'ailleurs ils
ont commencé à changer de paradigme
elles ont commencé à se dire qu'il faut
investir dans la dans la défense ça
c'est du jamais vu ça a vraiment été une
réelle heures mais là le gars sait si
c'est vraiment pour les citoyens ils
peuvent pas tout d'un coup changé partie
déjà marie jeanne non mais je pars sous
votre contrôle et je pense que déjà les
ya quand même des réserves
le gaz qui ont été et qui ont été faits
en allemagne et la problématique à gérer
c'est pour l'hiver prochain c'est pas
pour dans deux jours on se dit pas que
les allemands vont pas pouvoir se
chauffer donc il ya quand même une
projection qui effects et il faut
trouver une solution pour l'hiver
prochain il ya d'autres producteurs de
gaz ça coûte plus cher c'est ça c'est
pas l'heure où manquent pas de gaz on
manque c'est le coût du gaz qui va que
là dessus on écoute ya notre ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire
maintenant il faut accélérer notre
indépendance vis-à-vis du gaz russe donc
il faut d'abord que nous travaillons à
des solutions collectives européenne il
faut que nous accélérions le stockage de
gaz dès cet été et que l'on suive les
recommandations qui ont toujours été les
recommandations françaises c'est à dire
90 % de remplissage et de stockage pour
faire face à l'hiver 2022 2023 qui est
le véritable défi pour nous touche c'est
pas maintenant le défi le défi c'est
l'hiver 2022 2023 c'est là que il
pourrait y avoir des difficultés c'est
ces difficultés là que nous voulons
dissiper en portant cette idée de
stockage à 90% françois lévêque c'est
faisable ça parce que les capacités de
stockage les fins et ça se décide pas
d'un tease de choses il ya d'une part la
question du prix c'est à dire combien ça
va coûter puisque le prix du gaz
évidemment il ya une rareté donc les
prix augmentent surtout si
l'approvisionnement cesse de la russie
il faut la trouver des sources
différentes et qui vont être plus cher
et puis il ya quand même des problèmes
d'infrastructures des problèmes
d'infrastructures de capacité et sa
crème même si vous vouliez importer des
quantités
venant d'ailleurs et bien il ya des
terminaux méthaniers qui ne sont pas là
pour regagner le gaz qui voyage par
bateau à moins 180 degrés et donc on a
des limites liées aux infrastructures et
faasalele
lan wan il faut quoi un an deux ans
pourrait vendre la dent les tremplins
structure c'est pour ça qu'à mon avis la
réponse peut être parfaitement leurs
duels parce que il y a des possibilités
de substitution d'importation de gaz
russe à l'horizon trois ans il ya des
possibilités de substitution partielle à
un horizon trois mois il y en ad'autres
voilà donc la réponse je suis vraiment
très ferme sur cette idée de de réponse
graduelle
non mais pourquoi parce que le but c'est
de réduire les recettes budgétaires
de la russie en particulier des
oligarques husky et les essais hivernaux
qu'en parlant d' interrompre aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on est en train de financer il
n'y a pas de cire d'absolument c'est là
le grand le gaz est plus en plus cher et
on continue de le payer laquelle et
leurs deux grandeurs l'ordre de grandeur
on est l'heure de grandeur c'est la
centaine de milliards d'euros
par an d'accord à travers le gaz et le
pétrole c'est l'europe
c'est l'ordre de grandeur entre 50 et
200 parce que ça va dépendre des prix du
gaz et du pétrole voilà l'ordre de
grandeur c'est la centaine de milliards
la centaine de milliards d'euros et donc
on peut imaginer de réduire de moitié
par exemple vous avez déjà un effet de
votre sanction si au lieu que la russie
sort et les oligarques eux
s'enrichissent
250 milliards d'euros d'ici un trimestre
et bien vous en couper une partie donc
soyons soyons raisonnables parce que il
remplit aussi va être raisonnable ce que
poutine ne va pas deux semaines en
raison de devant de gaze à l'allemagne
histoire de bloquer et de je pense quand
l'économie pour lui c'est pas assez
s'il n'a pas d'intérêt pour l'économie a
qu' il n'y ait plus de recettes liées
aux exportations et bien ça lui est
complètement légal donc l'intérêt des
sanctions c'est quand même à la fois de
mesurer l'efficacité je suis pas sûr que
que la rupture totale et soir et non
soit deux fois plus efficace qu'une
diminution par deux des implantations
réussies intéressant je sais nous savons
c'est que pour l'instant les sanctions
elles sont aussi perçus comme ben voilà
l'europe la france montre sa fermeté
face à face à vladimir poutine et face à
l'armée russe parce que personne n'a
envie d'aller d'aller plus loin dans l'
escalade via un niveau d'acceptabilité
et des sanctions qui est fort pour
l'instant dans une toute l'europe parce
qu'ils ont sénat qu'il faut réagir qu'il
faut faire quelque chose en revanche ces
sanctions et
l'augmentation drastique de ces
sanctions qui consisterait à nous aussi
mettre un embargo sur les importations
pétrole et de gaz elle constitue un pari
un pari risqué ce pari c'est à dire ça
va stopper vladimir poutine ça va
l'arrêter dans sa folie guerrière et on
aura gagné peut-être ou peut-être pas et
donc c'est un vrai risque et ça ça va se
mesurer dans le temps dans les
prochaines semaines est ce qu'on va
pouvoir tenir est ce que ça va avoir un
réel impact pour répondre à ce que
disait monsieur effectivement une
réponse graduelle serait moins coûteuse
pour les européens mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne s'oriente pas vers
cette réponse graduelle puisque dans la
proposition de la commission formule est
aujourd'hui ils disent qu'ils veulent
atteindre une réduction de deux tiers
avant la fin de l'année 2022 des
importations de gaz russe deux tiers
c'est à dire presque la totalité en
moins d'un an donc là on a affaire à une
proposition drastique je ne sais pas si
elle pourra être tenu il parle de
biométhane d'hydrogène pour compenser
est ce qu'on en a les capacités les
moyens je ne suis pas certaine aide à
traverser une ambition latine ce qui est
intéressant dans le concert des nations
occidentales c'est la décision de joe
biden aujourd'hui c'est la première fois
qu'ils se désolidarisent des européens
et donc qui leur donne quand même
peut-être je ne sais pas quelle elle a
le pouvoir de l'influencé sur la
décision européenne mais la prise de
position de john dryden j'ai bien
compris que c'était n'avait aucun impact
sur l'économie américaine on voit la
moindre mais d'un point de vue
diplomatique il lé capital ces tendances
ont dans son discours là qu'il a
prononcé tout à l'heure il dit quand
même que cette décision a été prise en
concertation avec ses alliés on peut en
douter mais en tout cas c'est le
déclaratif 1 du président américain ce
qui est certain c'est que l'impact pour
les états unis est quasiment nulle
tandis que l'impact pour l'europe est
très important alors c'est peut-être au
sommet de versailles dont vous parliez
qu'on va avoir la réponse européenne sur
sur cette question de lambanyi il en
faudra c'est à dire que pour qu'elles à
la pilule passe il faut que eh bien il
ya une réponse
collective au niveau européen qui soit
trouvée pour que les ménages les plus
modestes puissent passer ces temps
difficiles pour que les entreprises
soient pas cool pas sous une facture
énergétique qui les empêche de consommer
parce que toute l'idée c'est de
véritablement essayer de de limiter la
hausse de la totalité des prêts donc
l'inflation pour l'instant à la hausse
et se limite sur sur les prix des
matières de la première l'alimentaire
donc il faut arriver à cibler dans
l'urgence c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller
très vite mais je pense que l'union
européenne est capable je vous rappelle
que l'année enfin il ya deux ans pour la
crise qu vide ils ont été capables de
mettre 750 milliards sur la table sami
anan c'était un peu trop long là mais
bon maintenant ils sont ils connaissent
les rouages ils ont vu que que ça marche
est extrêmement bien et pour comparer
aux états unis des états unis pour la
crise qu vide en gros ils ont mis cinq
mille milliards de dollars donc bon on a
des marges de manoeuvre même si c'est
par peut pas réellement comparer parce
qu'on l'a on n'inclut pas les plans
nationaux il n'empêche que
on va pouvoir
envisager réellement si on en a si on en
a une si c'est une volonté politique d'
arriver avec des solutions financières
alors justement on va on va déjà évoqué
une première réponse qu'est la réponse
du du gouvernement français vous parlez
de la continuation du poids qu'il en
coûte sauf que maintenant ça s'appelle
résilience quentin calmez vous pouvez me
rejoindre
bonsoir quand avec ce boxeur ce sera
hollande résilience qui était attendu ok
qu'est ce qu'on en sait et bien alors
justement thomas petit flashback 1 le
mot a été prononcé pour la première fois
c'était le jour de l'inauguration du
salon de l'agriculture
c'est emmanuel macron qui utilisent le
premier ce terme c'était donc le 26
février dernier on écoute
et donc nous sommes en train de bâtir et
le ministre le fera dans les prochaines
heures avec vous un plan de résilience
d'abord pour sécuriser pour nos filières
nos intrants
ensuite pour essayer au maximum de bâtir
des boucliers en termes de coûts au
niveau national et européen voilà on
comprend thomas hall à l'origine c'est
pour répondre donc et bien aux
inquiétudes des agriculteurs on est bien
au premier jour du sommet et culture
depuis c'est jean castex qu en jean
castex qui travaille sur le dossier avec
un plan qui doit être annoncé à la mi
mars le gouvernement attend notamment
l'accord de la commission européenne un
des guides des négociations auront lieu
jeudi et vendredi avec le sommet
européen extraordinaire qui se tient à
versailles l'idée avec ce plan est
d'aider de façon ciblée je cite les
filières touchées par les conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine comme
agriculteur donc qui voient les prix des
céréales flambent et mais ce ne sera pas
pour autant un nouveau quoi qu'il en
coûte écoutez bruno le maire s'était
lundi il ce ne sera pas un quoi qu'il en
coûte qui consisterait à verser de
l'essence sur un incendie sa portée des
canaux
efficaces sur ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin ce que m'a demandé présent la
république c'est de travailler sur une
réponse beaucoup plus globale est ce que
je soumettrai aux premiers mini c'est
une réponse plus globale qui s'appelle
un plan stratégique face un tournant
géopolitique dernier mot pour évoquer
les pistes qui sont sur la table thomas
on parle déjà des aides aux secteurs en
difficulté par exemple pour l'industrie
la russie exporte des matériaux utilisés
par l'industrie automobile ou
aéronautique comme l'aluminium ou le
palladium ou encore le nickel raffiné
autre exemple à une culture on l'a dit
puisque la russie est un exportateur
majeur d'engrais autre piste le
prolongement du gel des prix du gaz
jusqu'à la fin 2022 pour un coût estimé
à quand même 10 milliards d'euros et
enfin dernière mesure qui est sur la
table thomas un dispositif de soutien
aux ménages monnaie ce modeste merci
beaucoup merci quand un pur pour toutes
ces explications j'accueille avec nous
en visioconférence et me leclerc qui est
directeur d'études chez oddo que ça
bonsoir me leclerc un mot du du moral
économique des français es ce que vous
avez déjà voilà évaluer l'impact de
cette de cette guerre et donc de ses
conséquences en termes de pouvoir
d'achat sur le moral économique des
français alors sur le moral économique
des français oui pas encore sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais sur le moral
économique on a mené une enquête juste
avant le début de l'invasion de
l'ukraine et on a posé la même question
juste après déjà que les français
n'étaient pas forcément très
optimiste sur l'avenir économique de la
france est bien en neuf points en une
semaine et ça a perdu 9 points en a que
23 % des français qui nous disent je
suis optimiste pour je suis confiant
pour l'avenir économique de la france en
tout cas une vraie pessimisme qui
s'installe et on va le voir sur le
pouvoir d'achat a priori aussi dans les
prochains jours et on a vu le chiffre a
versé à 68% des français qui se disent
moins confiants dans l'avenir est là le
chiffre est en augmentation c'est cette
cette question et me leclerc du pouvoir
d'achat c'était déjà la première
préoccupation des français vous vous
l'avez évoqué dans cette campagne
électorale est ce que vous diriez que
c'est un point faible du du président
sortant des mails macron oui alors c'est
effectivement la principale
préoccupation des français ça l'était
avant la zone en ukraine et probablement
en parallèle évidemment de la guerre qui
est aussi un sujet de préoccupation pour
les français il ya un vrai niveau
d'inquiétude qui s'installe en parallèle
il ya une vraie préoccupation au pouvoir
d'achat et probablement que la housse de
l'essence du gaz etc eh bien c'était
encore plus ce sujet comme le sujet
majeur de cette élection présidentielle
et c'est problématique pour le
gouvernement et pour emmanuel macron
candidat qu'il en a conscience
probablement c'est un point faible pour
les français 80% des français estiment
avoir perdu du pouvoir d'achat sur
l'année en cours 79% nous disent que
emmanuel macron à un mauvais bilan sur
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat donc c'est
un vrai point faible sans être forcément
un point noir pour emmanuel macron aussi
une difficulté pour lui dans l'est dans
les semaines qui suivront jusqu'au
premier tour oui mais en l'occurrence
sur sur ce dernier aspect de
deux guerres en ukraine on peut pas
reprocher à emmanuel bach on voit sur
les lire l'opinion va pas reprocher à
emmanuel macron les dernières hausses de
prix des matières premières de l'essence
ou du blé
c'est à dire que les français
soutiennent largement à des sanctions
économiques contre la russie soutiennent
l'action de l'union européenne l'action
des franciliens progression sur ces
niveaux là maintenant il n'empêche que
quand ils vont voir le prix de l'essence
au delà des 2 euros à la pompe eh bien
ça sera une difficulté qui peuvent
reprocher au président là tout de suite
c'est pas encore palpables est ce qu'on
est vraiment sur le court terme mais
dans les dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent ça peut être une difficulté
pour un président qui aujourd'hui faut
le rappeler est de plus en plus favori
pour cette élection présidentielle dans
les intentions de vote il l'était déjà
auparavant cénevières renforce le cerf
d'une certaine manière parce que moi
l'expression mais le sert dans dans la
perspective de ce premier tour mais ça
peut être utile difficulté et un angle
d'attaqué pour c pour ses opposants
me leclerc je reviens avec vous dans un
instant joséphine staron ce plan de
résilience dont parlait quant à
l'instant est ce que vous diriez que
c'est aussi un amortisseur
d'impact dans l'isoloir le 10 avril
voyez ce que je veux dire alors s'il est
ce qu'il est aussi penser dans cette
perspective là j'imagine que oui
puisqu'on est en campagne mais pas
uniquement on est dans le cas d'une
guerre c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait inédit en europe donc emmanuel
macron a aussi la posture du chef d'état
qui doit aujourd'hui compenser les
conséquences négatives des sanctions
qu'il va lui même
faire peser sur sur la russie et defacto
sur le reste de l'union européenne et
les citoyens français ce qui est certain
c'est que cette solidarité massif qu'on
voit à l'égard de l'ukraine elle est
forte mais aujourd'hui on est dans un
contexte d'émotion dans un contexte de
stupeur de sidération face à ce qui se
passe à côté de chez nous d'ici quelques
semaines d'ici quelques mois lorsque
comme le disait monsieur la facture les
factures vont être de plus en plus
élevés la question de la solidarité va
se reposer et effectivement on pourra on
pourra reprocher à ce moment là emmanuel
macron les sanctions qu'aujourd'hui on
lui demande s'il est libéré s'il est
réélu tout à fait évidemment continuons
dans cette voie là d'être prudent parce
que il reste un peu plus de campagnes
parce que là c'est vrai que 80% thomas
80% des français qui trouve qu'ils ont
moins de pouvoir d'achat 79% qui leur
reprochent à emmanuel macron à un mois
du premier tour moi je veux bien que les
sondages le donnent à 30% et ultra
gagnant ultra favori mais il me semble
que ça ce type dit m de changer la donne
on est à un mois du premier tour c'est
court mais c'est loin et c'est françois
lévêque l'argent qui va être dépensés
par la france mais aussi par l'europe on
y reviendra voilà pour soutenir
l'économie les ménages les entreprises
on en dire un mot plus plus détaillée
ça représente quoi c'est à dire que pour
pour faire baisser je sais pas ou
limiter la hausse du prix du gaz de
quelques centimes ça coûte combien au
budget de l'état là où il ya on a une
mesure ça que les premières
les premières décisions qui ont été
prises eh bien elles sont autour de 20
me il ya de 20 milliards d'euros à on va
sans doute en prendre d'autres et donc
la facture va augmenter mais n'oubliez
pas que
l'argent ne pousse pas sur les arbres de
l'état a et donc
l'impression inverse de panneaux si les
consommateurs s'en trouve mieux parce
que il ya des subventions qui font que
les prix n'augmentent pas autant qu'ils
auraient dû augmenter en fonction du
marché et bien il y à des contribuables
mais ce sont aussi des consommateurs là
il ya des grands consommateurs qui sont
petits contribuables des grands
contribuables qui sont peut-être là
c'est plus rare des petits consommateurs
en tout cas d'énergie et donc cet argent
il vient de quelque part il vient des
contribuables soit d'aujourd'hui soit à
travers la dette des contribuables de
demain aussi sans doute pour demain ce
que vous êtes en cdd pour partie ça va
dépendre si c'est commencer comment cet
argent d'où vient cet argent et comment
cet argent est créé et donc il faut pas
oublier il faut pas oublier cette même
si les consommateurs voient plus
facilement parce que la facture bien
vous prenez de l'essence plus
régulièrement que vous ne payer d'impôts
et puis la tva en général vous ne la
voyez pas et vous l'avez oublié comme
contribuable oui c'était fini villers il
ya un élément dans l'équation qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est la croissance c'est à
dire que c'est cette nouvelle hausse du
prix des matières premières avec les
conséquences que ça sur certaines
entreprises ya des entreprises qui
doivent aujourd'hui cessé de produire
mettre leurs salariés en chômage partiel
tout simplement parce qu'elles peuvent
pas assumer la housse
gigantesque du prix du gaz donc il ya un
risque de blocage ou du oui c'est ça la
croissance voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle
la stagflation c'est à dire qu'on est en
situation où il ya beaucoup d'inflation
et pas de croissance c'est ce qu'on a
connu dans les années 70 c'est un des
pires scénarios
mais je pense que
les français sont quand même mais
globalement les européens prêts à
accepter
cette augmentation des prix de
énergétique puisque ont ils ont vu
concrètement ce que ça en coûtait de
dépendre de d'un régime autoritaire
lorsqu'on dépend de nos importations de
matières premières et si celui ci décide
de faire la guerre ou de bloquer ou de
plus vendre ces produits énergétiques et
bien on se retrouve et bien marron dans
l'histoire donc maintenant en fait à la
suite où il ya eu une première étape qui
était la crise sanitaire vous voyez
qu'on dépend des trop des pays émergents
mais que l'histoire des masques des
respirateurs avec la chine rebelote on
se retrouve en situation on voit que
cette dépendance et elle est aussi
énergétique et nous pose un problème
donc au fait on est obligé l'europe est
obligé d'avancer parce que seul parce
que les états unis sont pas confrontés
au même problème on voit que il va
falloir qu'on s'empare de ce sujet et
qu'on arrive avec des solutions et
collectivement je pense qu on est
capable de voir que ça va nous coûter
mais c'est pour assurer déjà nos
démocraties et nos libertés et surtout
assuré
dans sur le long terme notre
indépendance énergétique alimentaire et
technologique et ça devient
indispensable et ça tombe bien aussi
parce que l'europe est une épargne
colossale on n'en parle plus mais c'est
une réalité n'oubliez pas tout l'argent
qui a été mis de côté pendant cette
période covin donc là il va falloir s'en
saisir on n'est pas on n'est pas un pays
émergent sans sans moyens il faut
réorienter cette épargne qui a été mis
de côté plombé en seconde mais on a
plutôt de tendance à la prudence en tant
qu et en tant qu épargnants lui falloir
trouver des leviers d'incitation pour
que les français ou les autres falloir
viser non c'est un bas de laine parce
que l'argent existe pour aller financer
la recherche développement je vous
rappelle quand même que le vaccin du coc
vide a été trouvé en un an alors moins
d'un an alors qu'on s'attendait à 4,5 en
rappelez vous on se les est et enfin
lorsqu'on a mis les milliards sur la
table les états unis en mai les
meilleurs sur la table donc la recherche
a réussi à trouver ce vaccin alors il en
sera de même pour essayer de stocker le
gaz on a quand même des ingénieurs sur
tout est une question de moyens et de
volonté politique et à l'ab il faut
effectivement que la population
comprenne puis son ordre à changer de
paradigme et réussir à convaincre les
français épargnent en ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas de la bonne aubaine et les
amis aussi ont ils sont encore connus
que nous donc ils sont encore plus
s'agripper sur leur bas de laine ouais
quand on vous dit qu'on est en train de
changer de paradigme c'est vrai aussi
par de la transition écologique qui qui
veut peut nous rendre dépendants parce
qu'on parle de souveraineté aujourd'hui
que peut nous rendre dépendants à la
question des métaux rares ou alors par
exemple du lithium pour faire nos
batteries barbara pompili la ministre de
la transition écologique disait il ya
quelques quelques jours qu'il fallait
qu'on se mette à peut-être ouvrir des
mines pour trouver du lithium il y en a
en france y en a dans plusieurs régions
la bretagne l'alsace et c'est donc et
c'est intéressant parce que ça va même
un impact et notre diplomatie puisque
aujourd'hui notre diplomatie est
détournée vers les pays producteurs de
d'énergies fossiles il va peut-être
falloir la l'inversé la tournée vers
d'autres pays bref je trouve que c'est
vraiment une thématique qui est assez
passionnante et je voudrais quand même
qu'on reste sur la question des
entreprises parce que au milieu de tout
ça il ya des entreprises françaises qui
essayent de continuer de de faire du
profit et de payer leurs salariés
écoutons ce que dit elisabeth bornes la
ministre du travail sur le rôle des
entreprises de pour amortir cette crise
du pouvoir d'achat on écoute
moi je suis très attentive à ce que les
entreprises
amortissent au mieux et compense le
pouvoir d'achat que les ménages enfin
sur lesquels les ménages sont très
préoccupés aujourd'hui il ya eu beaucoup
de discussions mais ils des discussions
dans des entreprises il ya des
discussions dans des branches il faudra
évidemment que dans les prochains mois
on tienne compte de l'évolution des prix
comme de toute façon un certain nombre
de mécanismes le prévoient ou savait
qu'en france on a une revalorisation
automatique du smic en fonction de
l'inflation donc ce sont des mécanismes
qui seront sans doute appelés à jouer
dans les prochains mois françois lévêque
c'est passionnant ce que dix avaient
d'abord mais toutes les entreprises ne
vont pas pouvoir aider le
leurs salariés suis-je pas toutes des
bénéfices comme total énergie non les
entreprises sont dans des situations
très différentes mais là où le ministre
de l'économie et des finances a raison
d'insister c'est que les interventions
publiques en faveur des entreprises
doivent être ciblées 1 il s'agit d'aider
les entreprises si on prend le champ
qu'énergétique auxquels elles sont
confrontées et elles continueront d'être
confronté et bien il ya les entreprises
qui ne vont pas être confronté à ce choc
parce que elles consomment relativement
peu d'énergie et puis la part de
l'énergie dans leur coût est
relativement faible et alors que
d'autres entreprises qui peuvent être
aussi en plus soumises à la concurrence
internationale eh bien elles ont dans
leurs factures dans leur cou une part
très importante de l'énergie donc il
faut des mesures ciblées pour les
entreprises certaines entreprises n'ont
pas de problèmes pour passer les prix
sur les consommateurs
d'autres entreprises ne peuvent pas le
faire parce qu'elles sont en situation
de concurrence internationale
voilà donc il faut avoir une vision fine
et subtile et
d'éviter vraiment les aides que ce soit
auprès des entreprises ou auprès des
ménages qui ne soit pas ciblées en
matière énergétique il est clair qu'il
faut aider les ménages qui sont entre
égalité énergétique d'abord et avant
tout et les ménages qui peuvent accepter
de payer leurs factures 50 euros
d'électricité 50 euros de plus par an et
bien
ces ménages là c'est pas une difficulté
est là vous nous dites 50 euros mais
c'est vrai que c'est très important de
savoir
la variable quoi ça va être 50 c'est
sans ses deux sens et quand même pas du
tout de la même chose quand on a 50
euros ou 5 cents par exemple quel est
votre facture d'électricité
une idée de par ouais ouais enfin
parents non par mois et non un tout
petit appartement ouais d'accord assure
en général si vous voulez on est on est
à moins de 1000 euros en moyenne ait
moins de 1000 euros par an dans la
consommation dans les comptes dans la
consommation et donc et donc si vous
augmentez les prix mais bien ça dépend
du revenu des ménages et aux cibles bien
les ménages en précarité énergétique
ceux pour qui les dépenses d'énergie
c'est 20 % 1 de leur budget donc on les
connaît ils sont repérés maintenant et
donc ces catégories sociales à des
ménages qui sont aussi des électeurs et
me leclerc je reviens vers vous parce
que on l'a dit à ce pouvoir d'achat en
tête des préoccupations des français
mais koné style pour autant les
programmes économiques des candidats
forcément il ya certaines illusions qui
marque beaucoup les l'électorat on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps les
droits de succession il ya des mesures
c'est intéressant par rapport à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur les
économies d'aujourd'hui
quand on va redonner du pouvoir d'achat
c'est aussi des impôts pour demain il ya
quelque chose qui plaît beaucoup en
général aux électeurs c'est les
suppressions de taxes de tva ou d'autres
taxes c'est le cas en particulier sur
l'essence sur les les coûts de l'énergie
qui explose en ce moment donc c'est un
vrai sujet ils sont pas forcément très
bien informé sur sur les programmes
économiques mais il ya une vraie attente
on a les deux tiers des français qui
nous disent cette élection
présidentielle aura un impact sur mon
pouvoir d'achat donc c'est encore un
sujet sur lesquels les français
considèrent que le politique a une
certaine prise ya beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels les français considèrent que
les politiques ne peuvent pas changer
grand chose sur le pouvoir et chassé pas
le cas c'est pas très rare les deux
tiers c'est quand même un chiffre assez
élevé et ensuite dans le détail quand on
a testé tout un tas de mesures
économiques des candidats et comme je
vous le disais celles qui sont les plus
appréciées c'est souvent les
suppressions de taxes bien davantage que
les chèques qui nous concernent souvent
qu'une partie de la population c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il ya un soutien plus
massif donc suppression des taxes sans
forcément les français est toujours
conscience que ces taxes sont aussi des
impôts et donc qu'elle peut servir à
financer des services publics notamment
joseph insa ou est-ce que vous pensez
que les les les propositions en matière
économique des des candidats et
candidates peuvent malgré tout il reste
un mois finir par émerger parce que là
on a l'impression que tout est écrasé
par l'actualité et crédible
tout est forcément écrasé par
l'actualité en ukraine parce que on
attend aussi de savoir de connaître les
autres candidats attendent de connaître
ce fameux plan de résilience dans le
détail qui va être présentée par le
premier ministre pour savoir aussi ce
qu'ils peuvent proposer en complément ou
en remplacement
on dit que quoiqu'il en coûte c'est pas
tout à fait ça aujourd'hui parce que ça
va être ciblés defacto tout l'argent
public qui va être à nouveau investie
pour compenser les conséquences
négatives des sanctions économiques ce
qu'on doit faire parce qu'on peut pas
faire peser trop de poids sur les
ménages et sur les entreprises et bien
cet argent là il ne servira pas à autre
chose donc le prochain président quel
qu'il soit qui arrivera à l'elysée en
mai prochain
nos aura des des caisses quasiment vides
et ne pourra pas mener les réformes qui
intéresse aussi les français on parle de
la réforme de la justice du système
éducatif de la santé autant de secteurs
pour lesquels ça va être difficile
aujourd'hui d'investir madame le
rappelait on va avoir de nombreux
investissements à faire pour assurer
notre souveraineté dans nombreux
domaines technologiques numériques
énergétique au niveau européen donc
finalement tout ça ça va être des
sacrifices nécessaires pour l'avenir
mais qui vont être difficiles à
encaisser à l'instant t oui mais on va
conclure là dessus stefan müller avec
une europe qui change de pied c'est ce
que vous me disiez tout à l'heure oui la
règle des 3% elle n'est pas près de
revenir oui ça devait effectivement
revenir d'ici la fin de l'année donc là
on peut dire que c'est encore repoussée
d'une année donc on n'est pas menacé par
la rigueur budgétaire
même si les allemands vont pas vouloir
n'accepteront pas n'importe quoi et tout
ils l'ont déjà dit en disant que
effectivement il fallait peut-être un
plan d'accord mais derrière avec tout le
monde les mêmes objectifs et la même
rigueur in fine et on fera pas n'importe
quoi avec l'argent de l'europe et en
particulier l'argent d'allemagne et donc
on attend pour les prochains jours à la
fois le plan français et le plan
européen pour savoir à quel point notre
économie sera soutenu en cette période
de deux conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine merci beaucoup merci est
évidemment participer à ce débat ici et
en duplex